you just full of food until they make
babies right you for over a year she
drives you absolutely nuts it's great
like the [ __ ] out of them sort of
straight pretend you're an alien trying
to explain you don't want to someone go
I'm an alien I would rather not how to
cook like a rancher blow one continuous
for seven seconds did they bond that
rock if you look right and look left all
you see in the entire field of view is
just the like nothing but the and that's
like astonishing on so many levels it's
huge enormous beyond big my knuckles oh
I can move oh this is normal oh this
completely natural Amber's oh I got
something it was it was good that's all
it was that's all though caught it was a
cup I'm gonna splatter you with my room
green hot better but not perfect
considering that thick and still they
look pretty happy actually probably
because they've actually been [ __ ]
cared for because I'm a good Papa did
you just look at my and then become
overwhelmed with disgust like um somehow
I did a good thing my goood in the right
place yeah
I think for quite a while just kind of
talking to myself you're so low huffing
with your pink mine is blue for some
reason nothing strange about the way
that looks oh now he's gone limp so I'm
gonna try to get through this without as
much as possible so that I control the
white-hot burning inside of my soul but
it's not what you do you name five
things you would not in your bedroom go
ahh leave our burden I am an effective I
can't wait to write poetry on the ways
of which I myself
watching you guys